love the concept of Love is is one of
the most Central themes in in Sufism the
Sufi poetry is very popular around the
world many people read Rumi for example
and when you read when you read Rumi
one of the things you'll notice very
quickly is this language of love which
is everywhere and in different ways you
talk about
lover and beloved and love as a kind of
Cosmic Force
um many people even assume
that you know because they read certain
translations of Rumi that often take
away the the sort of Islamic content of
his poetry they assume that he's just a
love poet because when you read those
poems if you don't have if you don't
know about the Theology and and
metaphysics and all that stuff that's
that's built into that poetry it can
mean just like any other love poem so
love is a very very central theme in
super Sim